THAT AT ALL AND I’M GLAD TO
HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
IT’S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
DR. ALLEN MENDOSA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALAN JACKSON
SOCIETY AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
DR. MENDOSA, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> A PLEASURE TO BE WITH
YOU.
>> Tucker: SO DO YOU THINK
WE ARE OVERSTATING IT WHEN
WE DESCRIBE NORTH KOREA AS
BASICALLY A PRISON?
>> NO, OF COURSE NOT.
IT IS BASICALLY A PRISON.
THIS IS THE WORLD’S MOST
OPPRESSIVE REGIME.
IT IS INDEED A PRISON CAMP.
YOU CAN’T LEAVE.
YOUR LAST GUEST WAS SORT OF
SMEEG BEFORE SHE CAME ON,
BUT I HAVE TO SAY MOST
EXTRAORDINARY SET OF SORT OF
POINTS, DIFFERENT POINTS PUT
TOGETHER IN A SORT OF A
POLICY STATEMENT.
LOOK, THIS IS A STATE WHICH
EXISTS AND RUNS ON TERROR.
IT RUNS ON TERROR.
IT RUNS ON TORTURE.
IT RUNS ON IMPRISONMENT, AND
IT RUNS ON ENSURING THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE ARE AT
THE BECK AND WHIM OF THE
REGIME.
IT IS INDEED A PRISON CAMP.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
>> Tucker: WHY THE IMPULSE?
YOU HAVE WATCHED THE
REACTION OF THE
INTERNATIONAL LEFT TO A LOT
OF THESE DIFFERENT REGIMES
OVER THE YEARS.
WHY THE IMPULSE TO DEFEND,
TO SIDE WITH, MAKE EXCUSES
FOR REGIMES THAT ARE
INDEFENSIBLE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY HATE THE WEST?
>> THERE IS AN EXTRAORDINARY
ROMANCE THE LEFT ACTUALLY
BELIEVES IN WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE REGIMES.
IT STARTS WITH THE IDEA THAT
ACTUALLY WE CAN CONVERT
THESE PEOPLE SOMEHOW.
AND IT GOES ALONG THE LINES
ACTUALLY WE HAVE SOMETHING
IN COMMON WITH THEM.
YOU ARE RIGHT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE FACT THAT THE U.S. IS
FREQUENTLY SEEN AS THE SORT
OF CHIEF ENEMY OF THESE
REGIMES IS SOMETHING THAT
ACTUALLY APPEALS TO THE LEFT
AS WELL.
AND TAKE THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER, YOU LOOK AT THOSE
TWO THINGS TOGETHER AND YOU
REALIZE THAT YOU GET A KIND
OF COMPLETE OPPOSITE TO WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF IT WAS A
RIGHT WING REGIME.
IF THAT WAS THE CASE THE
LEFT WOULD BE FIRST OUT ON
THE STREET MUST IGNORE THEM.
WHEN IT COMES TO SOMEONE WHO
IS ANTI-AMERICAN, THEY HAVE
A VERY DIFFERENT VIEW.
>> Tucker: SORT OF STRANGE
THOUGH IF YOU GO LIVE IN THE
WEST, IN THE U.K., THE U.S.
ENJOY THE FRUITS OF THE
SOCIETY.
WHY DEVOTE YOUR LIFE TO
DESTROYING IT.
ONLY THE LEFT DOES THAT
RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HERE YOU COME TO THE CRUX OF
THE MATTER.
WHY IS IT THE CITIZENS OF
OUR COUNTRY WHO ENJOY FREE
SOCIETIES, WHO ENJOY THE
ABILITY TO ARGUE AND ENJOY
THE ABILITY TO DISCUSS.
GO OUT ON A LIMB TO DEFEND
DICTATORS OPPRESSIVE REGIMES
WHO PREVENT THEIR CITIZENS
FROM DOING THAT IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY, EXTRAORDINARY
TURN OF EVENTS WHEN THAT
HAPPENS.
WHAT YOU SHOULD BE SAYING,
WHAT TRUE LIBERALS SHOULD BE
TOO LONG IS ARGUING FOR THE
INHABITANTS OF THOSE
COUNTRIES WHO ARE SUBJECTED
TO HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSES.
GETTING THEM THE SAME RIGHTS
THAT THEY THEMSELVES
ENJOYED.
YOU DON’T HAVE THAT AT ALL.
>> Tucker: WHY FATHERS
SHOULD BE NICE TO THEIR